appears to be recording anyways cheers
i'm fine
[Music]
spoilers by the way hi welcome
i'm starting from scratch this is going
to be
a words of radiance postmortem
talk discussion whatever you want to
call it if you don't like spoilers
just don't watch the video
there are pros and cons to having this
book in this size
and the pros to me are it's not going to
fall on your head and crush your [ __ ]
skull in
[Music]
words of radiance is superior to the way
of kings
hot take i haven't read oathbringer yet
or the next one
but way of kings so far is the weakest
it has a way slower pace way less
focus in words of radiance you have the
eshenai
uh interludes that pop in that show us
there's going to be a massive storm
massive
consequences at the end of this book and
it's set up in a way that where you feel
like the tension building also
what helps with the pacing of this book
is the countdown in
dalinar's room every time he goes crazy
in the high storms that that sequence
though that countdown really helps with
the pacing because you know
okay there's this many days until [ __ ]
goes down and
that keeps you really engaged whereas in
the way of kings it's just kind of
oh dalinar is he's trying to unite
everyone and he doesn't know how
and adeline is being a little a piece of
[ __ ]
and kaladin is just like sad all the
time
and then that climax comes and that's
when
everything hit me in the way of kings
was like
that climax when that came it was
amazing it was it was beautiful oh
another reason why this book beats way
of kings
the interludes [ __ ] slap okay the
interludes and wave kings were
i honestly don't remember but the
interludes
oh boy you got risen that's a long ass
chapter but it's so good
and weird and you get to see those you
know the islands that move
and then she's just like doing all this
daring [ __ ] to try to impress the leader
i was like i don't want to read this
long ass thing but then i was like wow
that was actually
really fun i like that character and
lift
same thing you know great ending to the
lift sequence
see even though these interludes
sometimes come during the middle of this
great stuff
sanderson always knows how to have
each interlude build to something
there's never anything that's just
inconsequential there's never something
that's just
most of them have great endings that
just give you a bit of
you know weight
so annoying i know people
love kaladin i like caledon i think he's
a great character i think he was really
good
in the first book the first book he's
just like a regular guy
who's you know enslaved and then forced
to be a bridgeman
and he's depressed and suicidal and
goes through all of that and then he
brings the bridge team together and
he's basically given everything he could
possibly want
at the end of way of kings and now he's
coming into words of radiance
he has all these good things going for
him he has you know he's working for a
guy who he actually likes
who lets him be a captain which is is a
light eyes position he shouldn't even be
doing that job
kaladin and even though he has it all he
is complaining about pretty much
everything and it gets to a point where
i start
i'm reading this and i start going man
he's
really becoming sort of a douchebag and
i mean that in the kindest way possible
caledon
i don't know why i'm acting like he's
right here and i'm talking to him but
i'm sorry caledon but
adeline the way he talks to him
is uncalled for and simply gross
how dare he speak to allied eyes that
way and you know he's just stoking
adeline's rage and i mean come on
caledon is just like being
an [ __ ] what does he expect to happen
shalon's backstory is so good
honestly it's better than caledon's
backstory caledon's backstory
with the happy family and the little
brother who
i'm i'm sorry tian if that's a tien tien
i i'm glad he died i'm gonna say that
you know tien deserved to die he's the
most deserving to die
of everyone in this whole series so
annoying and he collects
rocks get a real hobby
i don't know i felt like i expected
everything that happened in caledon's
backstory where shalon's backstory
holy [ __ ] you think that her father's
just this abusive bastard and it's
really interesting and how she's
you see how it shapes her character how
it turns her into the person that she is
today trying to cheer up her brothers
it's just very accurate and very full of
so much depth
and then at the very end we realized
that
she killed her mom and her dad was just
i guess
abusive on the side or she just had bad
parents she killed both her parents
which is uh you know
that's nobody wants to do that
complaints it had a great beginning ton
of momentum
the momentum died after yazna died
shalon is dealing with that lady who's
the scam artist who
ends up dying and going through trap
i i don't care it was it's just boring
just get to the planes i want to see
what happens i want to see you interact
with these other people
i feel like i'm squinting way too much
okay i'm i'm squinting a normal amount
who cares
it's fine it's fine i'll fix it in post
more complaints
uh the ghostbloods are boring it's the
least
interesting part going on in the story
for me and i know it's probably building
up to something really cool
and i can't miss out on it but didn't
care that much about it
[Music]
my favorite moment in the whole book
shalon and kaladin
in the chasm that's my favorite sequence
in the whole thing
they end up down i think it's a little
unrealistic that they're both like huh
i must have saved her and she's like huh
i must have saved him with my
powers they've been bickering i honestly
thought the first time they interacted
with each other
in the palace was a little too quippy
a little too combative but i
i really like their progression as
characters and in the chasm it's just
so beautifully done work caledon can
kind of
see outside of his own pain because he
becomes so
wrapped up in his own perspective that
he thinks there's no
way a light eyes like shalon could have
any
hardship there's that beautiful line
where he talks about how
seeing how she dealt with her trauma
inspired him
and it's just so beautiful and
i could see the seeds of real love
even though i like adeline and shalon
but i do feel like
sanderson is hinting that there are
issues
with them that they may do not work out
necessarily
shalon doesn't want to be controlled
yada yada we'll get into that
but the chasm scene that was really good
the scene where kaladin gets sill back
fantastic when he's fighting moash and
that other dude
that was just really cool other
favorite moment is sabario and his wife
when they just go to the shattered
plains with everybody
and and they're just chilling and that
scene where like the storms
the everstorm is raging around them and
he's just like chilling there eating
grapes and she's like reading her novel
and they're just like oh yeah we
ordered everyone to go to the thing and
be
saved and um yeah so anyways dal and i
what's up with you i vibe i vibe with
suberial
he's a wise character in this universe
and i look forward to his
his progress in these stories and my
absolute favorite
moment in this whole book is not the
climax which was really good
but the duel adeline facing the four
shard bearers
oh my god that was so good that was so
my my back was sweating
i'm like oh two shard bears this is not
gonna turn out good dude like you should
not have done this fight something bad
is going to happen and then
four shard bearers show up and it's like
things just get
keep getting worse and worse and then
renarin comes out
and it's like oh poor you poor child
like don't
don't oh my god so
so hard to watch and kaladin comes
and oh that scene i would reread this
whole book
just to re re-read that obviously they
end
in a down note because kaladin is a
ridiculous [ __ ] pain in the ass
i stand by what i say kaladin is is
worse
shalon is the best character
in the series so far she's the best
absolute worst moment in the book is
when kaladin gives
his plate and shard blade to [ __ ]
moash
another reason why calisthene is the
worst evelyn is with him
in prison for weeks and he comes out and
he's like you know what
you helped me with this duel even though
the whole scheme blew up in our faces
but you saved my life
and now i'm giving you the shards
caledon
you know he could have been like well
you know i just i can't accept this
you know give it to someone important
but he's just like ah have this moash
even though i know you want to [ __ ]
kill the king
you really think moash is the best
person for that for the shards
his anger his sense of revenge blinds
him
makes him very frustrating and honestly
it
leans into obnoxiousness in this book
a little bit moa moash really kaladin
really give it a rock jesus or somebody
else anybody this might be a
controversial
take i thought the scene where kaladin
realizes he needs to save
the king's life was really goofy
kaladin for half of this book is having
issues
realizing okay maybe i should save the
king's
life even though sill has left him which
is obviously because he decided he's
going to
go through with this thing with moash oh
yeah you know
it's better to kill him like really is
it that much better like galin are still
basically in charge and that's my issue
not much else
is is going to change or get better by
killing hello car
oh i guess you're right you know maybe
killing people is good which
that's not the calendar from the way of
kings you know where
he is trying to save every single soul
no matter what
now he's just like ah [ __ ] him he's he's
the worst
because of some [ __ ] that happened to
moash
kaladin has this scene where finally he
goes talks to
the the swordmaster guy i forget his
name's the hell something like that
and he's just like do whatever helps you
sleep at night caledon
and then kaladin has this emotional
moment where he's doing his
spear thing and he's like man what's
going to help me sleep at night what's
going to help me sleep at night oh maybe
not killing a person
that'll that'll help so you know and i
i get that it builds up to the point
where he's in that line that just like
made me cringe a little bit where he
says
that elokar
is dalinar's
no [ __ ] dude it it works it pays off
because caledon helps save
ella car and the scenes work
really well the climax works really well
everything clicks into place
and that's what i love about sanderson's
writing is that
all of the plot threads converge
in such a beautiful way in these great
scenes so that
all of this expectation pays off very
well
even though occasionally that building
of expectation
hurts and building towards these great
scenes
ends up hurting character a little bit
because it feels a little forced
in terms of their motivation i felt like
caledon's motivation was
a little forced in the book i guess
that's what i'm trying to say moral of
the story
uh okay if there's no more words of
radiance
buy it at your local bookstore
i don't know why i'm sponsoring i don't
know i'm saying you should buy this
product because
this is a spoiler review so likely
people who are watching this have
already read it hit that like button
you silly goose and remember when you
are
faced with terrifying insurmountable
odds
there is a sprint floating around you
who has abandoned you forever and is
probably not going to come back
because you resent the rich thanks for
watching